and that's when Karen said good night
Wesley I'll most likely shoot you in the
morning and she did bullshit okay
he tells you before it's oh hey can I
start and I have a good opening line
because that lets take it away my
opening light which was bullshit that's
a fucking wesley dies fucking wesley I
think okay serial killer what a warning
yeah a cop the woman did the chair you
don't leave a loaded gun on them he's
not more eerie okay oh really
I'll bullshit simple that doesn't really
makes it no this is supposed to scare
you he puts up again why would he put it
on the ticket this is like the Secretary
to like the biggest crime boss in like
this universes universe and he goes out
like fucking that like fucking ivy I
just and I'm not saying like they're
making it up that kind of bullet yeah
I'm just saying bullshit that that is
fucking Wesley that's a cool character
and he's awesome and he he does not
deserve to go out that way you just know
that actor when doing because he's like
reading this is a wait fucking what Oh
are you disturbed that your died on
disturb my come on like a bitch I get
idiot moron bitch this is awful
multiple things first my good friend
Wesley is not a serial killer
guy it makes us think we firmly
established she's not a good killer he's
never done it before but he's good at
selling shit off and then why would he
think he could do it
i well he wasn't planning on being
interrupted okay
so stupid
at any point even if she was on the far
right she could just reach across grab
the gun like like she did i I do have to
admit when I first saw it when he says
you didn't think I'd be stupid enough to
put a loaded gun in front of me when she
shoots if I was like oh turns out I was
stupid yeah like fuckin what the doors
the episodes fine it's a good episode
but that look you pissed me off I think
I think it shows how really fuckin
confident you
was in himself and how really he
completely underestimated their I think
he just thought others fine I'm just
gonna be scaring some little girl here
like this not a problem
she was drugged she's like whatever no
III think he just literally just was
drunk on his own see now right there
like the phone rang and I could have
grabbed the gun from you
yep I don't have a gun I would have my
phone on if I had a gun I have enough
for a V log that's still pretty stupid
but I would have it off you made the
same fucking mistake he just did I'm not
trying to kill somebody or persuade I
don't I love God I wouldn't have a lot
of documents jump it so we firmly
established that serial killing isn't
that was Lee's Forte it's me
cuz I can make a word out of that I'm so
angry wasn't at least ironic that he was
brought down by the phone the very thing
that brought him closer to gratify his
own fucking stupidity I just like I love
that character you know at first we set
up with the kingpin that you know what
we were saying like you know God he
seems so emotional and he seems you know
had certain elements but he's clearly on
top of things for the most part even
weak starts to stray you know there's
sort of this sense of getting a bad way
except maybe now I mean we don't know
maybe too much but it's like he always
seems to be on top of he has all these
backup plans I mean backup plan to type
of backup plans partly because of Wesley
like he's done motherfucker that shit
all that stuff up and for him to go out
like this and nobody else there nobody
else there why just fucking him why do
it inside its a Laura lesson don't step
outside of your comfort zone zone
oh I come easily never done that before
I'm waiting for right now with a loaded
weapon well then again he was he did
make threats to that what was a cop
earlier in the series but then again he
had like minions and this was like I
applied to me 101 I'm waiting you know
like the twist in this scene because
first off offering him a job in PIN home
fuck is wrong everything Wesley did in
the moment of his death leading up to
going out was completely wrong again
it's just like it was so not that
character and everything else even when
they - you know I think offering the job
was probably the best thing no you want
a shower
what killer oh no killer eventually but
convinced what eventually eventually
think eventually he'll have to kill uric
net and he's the one who has the problem
with the fact that they're leaving a
trail of bodies everywhere
but yeah now it's his body fucking
idiots it won't yes but that's the whole
theme it's martyrs
sacrificing themselves okay you know you
gotta give it this bet you didn't see
that one coming no I my eyes were wide
open I guess I can and I did make like a
very Tim Allen yeah I'm waiting for like
you know couple of pallets
but I'm like oh and second I like Wesley
I think I was like we all like Wesley
the man was not his time was not his
time was not his time
well if there's anything we can thank DC
for its a fact that nobody ever really
dies in comics so who the hell knows
bullshit how he died you know he came
back if you can't bet I figure hey you
know it was bullshit how you died I'll
fuck it's stupid but maybe some part of
a master plan no no you know if we
brought back to life I would shoot him
just yes fucking die like a moron
now you're dying people were like Anwar
cuz I killed you alright I'm having
trouble rationalizing it okay still a
Wesley scene and less museums are by
default really good except for this one
this is the one punched Wesley scene
that is done oh okay well are you
finished
yeah so I go through the episode rusty
episodes really good
let's go vision i-i've just got a crap
on all character no aunty it was a good
episode um more and more playing the as
you're saying so the yin and yang of the
two I mean they're both both Murdock and
Fisk are kind of in mourning they have
both been given warnings about veering
from the path and what they will become
if they go down you know elements of
fate and and their character and
environment and stuff martyrs sacrifice
yeah I mean so dogs and cats living
together man necessary um so that stuff
was all wonderful uh check think what
else I'm just so wrapped up in Wesley I
will say this I because now I'm not sure
if it's um what's the name I'll go yeah
I'm not sure I'm not sure if it's her
who did cuz there's they're asking too
much if it was her it usually in shows
that's sort of what they do to me it's
always somebody there is a list of
suspects because it could also meet the
Japanese but now I don't think it said I
mean might might might it was either
Wesley or the patch Adams guy and now I
think it's the patch Adams guy that
that's my guess I mean my image of my
original thought was we're kind of make
doctors but it makes supervillains area
yeah no rich I was thinking maybe oh I
just gotta interject and say I love his
early scene soon I resolve in the glass
don't you think I should be exactly yeah
there's no what if it isn't her yeah you
know I mean what am i invisible I mean I
think that if I had to guess I say that
right they're playing very much that
it's not him which is why I'm kind of
thinking it is and she might just my
fair line is and what if it was her then
it's been a pleasure doing business
what's your great line yeah don't get
shot by a blonde by a gun you put down
the only lightly drugged her and she
could clam in and out okay I said I was
as a Noah stop sorry everyone makes
mistakes
Wesley walks um - no that was so good I
think with a blank on her name no the
blonde
I believe watch this in a while Karen
Karen um I will start debating whether
or not it made sense to have her like
cuz obviously Murdock and foggy they're
on opposite sides now and nobody's can't
listen to her and she's just like you
can just pull it together and just you
know we're supposed to be a team and I
just I wasn't sure if that was founded
or not because I'm the one she's got no
one else to her yeah I mean the wreck is
uric is bowing out is still pissed at
you no one rightfully sub know nothing
don't agree I'm saying like the way she
was kind of like you know she was kind
of shaking and the tears we're going and
stuff and I was thinking like Laura
turning it too much screen Oh we'll get
to that but no I don't know I couldn't
because I'm thinking about where she
started off from - and it's not like
this is someone that was totally used to
being in you know fists of constant
let's go get him and stuff at the same
time I feel like you know she has worn
awesome attackers and stuff like that
and she is like hey let's get these
bastards I don't wanna give up I don't
wanna give up so and to me I would
imagine she'd be more like angry than
like you know was that no because she's
having all of her lifelines pulled away
from her basically because she could
depend on Murdock wanting to stop this
she could depend on foggy as a friend
she could depend on Urich all three now
boots are gone yeah yeah pretty much is
going up in smoke
so honestly I think her reaction makes a
lot of sense I think she's looking at
this like well great now what do I have
like I thought we were gonna bring this
guy down and now it's just me versus the
world no I was definitely saying is it
you know I can see being angry I just
wasn't sure about you know being sad
about it do you know that I wasn't sure
cuz I felt like she's come a long way
since like Episode one I mean now she
really is like moving forward and taking
say you know fucking killing Wesley
again the whole balance thing it's like
one side loses something then the other
has to lose something it's like that all
this talk about martyrs and sacrifice
and that we lose Wesley she's lost her
life lines like this is a common theme
like it's this constant battle between
good and evil and they just keep taking
each other out I'm surprised how much I
like that uh that bitch foggy slept with
my best friends forever and I don't care
yeah there's like she's just so
comfortable in how full of herself and
not carry that she is that okay I always
respected will you need that it's a nice
counterpoint to Karen who is so over
caring about everything that ends it's
like oh man give up the cause for one
second no I think there's something to
where everybody does KITT everybody has
like a deep you know caring goal and a
purpose and they they care about
something everybody does and that's not
bad at all it adds so much but the same
time it is nice just to have a selfish
jerk to that's like not that complicated
oh and she did a very well and we got
Potter um the always have a guy making
the suit yes
you know it's my I was watching that and
my first thought way started crying I'm
like boy this is like a laughs and
writing where did this come from and
then you sort of see like oh you she
helped me when I get confused and stuff
it's like oh okay you know that took me
a minute yeah definitely I think a
different Potter than the one I was
remember from the comics but it'll be
interesting to see where they go the
original Potter was more of like a
villain who reformed well now there and
I went through that in all of like 10
sec yeah kind of working for King but
even then it was more like blackmail the
original guy was like he was like a
fashion designer or something it was
weird it was weird and then he's like
i'ma build a suit and rob banks or
something it was definitely different
than this and I didn't know I like the
connection between that's how he finds
this guy to make this is obviously
leading to the suit you know and the
material and stuff I don't know how I
felt that it turns out
full-time Kington with pen he had a suit
under that because I really like the
idea that it's all muscle or whatever
fat muscle whatever you call it uh you
know I think he actually could not get
through cuz it just seems so much more
unstoppable that way than the idea
I'll just deal with the suits often
haven't seen this much fun it depends on
the tone for I mean it makes sense to be
prepared but the same time there's
something so badass I get that is kind
of muscles are so good so far there does
not seem to be a lot of supernatural
element or really that kind of comic
book II like I'm just strong like Hulk
like you know I mean he's definitely
like a gorilla but so in that kind of
way it's kind of like Batman is like no
he's got body armor and he's got things
to help him out um considering this is
the Marvel comic universe though yeah
I'm not sure what I don't know I don't
know what tone they're going for but if
it's don't looking at the world star
yeah see that's the thing this seems so
far removed this show from all of that
going on in the movies that it doesn't
bother me but if they're gonna start
bringing the Marvel comic universe from
the movies and stuff and everything into
this show into this project and then
yeah I have to wonder to say I I died
for me the jury's still out on that but
I mean it's not like oh my god that
ruins the kingpin I mean that's not it
at all it's more like that's just oh
he's a tiger you insinuate anything like
that no I mean there was just something
when he's like you know yeah you're not
gonna find me what a one and you know
bitch yeah and you're just barely even
moved wait he's hit no he's doing all
this stuff he's just standing that I
don't know there's always something so
intimidating in any movie or any story
when this giant is like yeah come on and
you go and do everything he doesn't even
movie she's got was like a little bit of
smiling come on come on do this is it my
turn now you know it's there is
something so intimidating and then
knowing there's a brilliant mind behind
that too it just makes them all the more
scary so the idea there being armor
under there it's kind of like you know
an opening of swinging up Fiske one of
my favorite scenes with him and Vanessa
is him talking about how like I think
make that time yeah I first off I
realized I couldn't really pray because
it was false therefore I will pray for
you I'm like touching instead I'm
smiling like you know it'll be okay
I'll make the dot my wife turned to me
what we saw this cuz I watch it before
Doug ever David she just goes like
that's how I know I married who's like
so cute than Adam zambese the other way
yeah I don't like advanced ma'am guys
yeah I will prove you but I'll make sure
that they die up no I like that too I
mean anything because it's it's romantic
in the way only kingpin can be and what
I like about this Vanessa I think more
than get the comics I thought she kind
of got a little more like you know get
out of the business but this one just
seems on board with it like really she's
like no I want to be with you I don't
care what you do it's a sick bizarre
relationship but through it they find
love yeah they both agree on those very
sick twisted identity like you know whoa
lo moment for me besides Wesley's death
and I think this gets we were talking I
think Lance about how this show is so
good that would it kind of dip are when
it kind of dips into cliche it kind of
jolts you out of it for a second like oh
yeah this show is capable of dumb like
it's so rare but what he says like you
know what do you want me to do about me
to go to you sued who's like no a symbol
oh my god really did you just say that
you know like this would have been fine
way back in 1989 in Tim Burton's Batman
or like no I
I'll even argue like
mm yeah we were like Batman Begins to
like it has been so that kind of line
has been so dumb to death oh my gosh
yeah you know in when I come on you're
better than this
when I first heard when I first saw
Batman Begins and it got to that point
where he was talking about this symbol I
mean it was honestly it was so well
written that line you know as a man I
can be destroyed Meeker I mean open as a
symbol like yeah I'm from last time and
it was so well put that I think now
anyone that uses that line or that word
it's like China's gonna think back to
Batman Begins in the same way that you
cannot write a line along lines of with
great power comes great responsibility
or if you put something like that in
your movie people are automatically
gonna think a spider and be like yeah
yeah yeah this has been done to death
great Howard responsibility it's just it
was when those lines is like when he
said a symbol I was like oh oh
like I've met every comic know all I
could think of to say if this was 12 13
years old or it would have been the
ideas been done to death
but things that's surprisingly still
work the cliched i'ma talk to the old
priest in the church scene still worked
really well well you know actually that
paralyzed me of some of the want to
bring up you know and maybe I don't
really trust there's like a
anti-christian thing necessarily going
on but there has been like Oh a really
hard kind of like you know oh those
assholes and I'm not gonna act like I
don't get why cuz there are just such
extreme as dicks out there's an anti
silent thing going on yeah but but I
think there is watching this again I
mean we grew up Catholic yeah you know
Roman Catholic and watching this again
I'm realizing how rarely I hear it
talked about in a positive way and it's
nice when it's done with intelligence
and it's smart and it's comforting and
which I'm not against making fun of even
we make fun of it openness I'm not even
sure it's always really in a positive
way it's just in an ambiguous way their
conversations always skirt around good
and evil and it's hard to tell where
either of them are coming from yeah
no but or her
like that was my favorite thing because
that's something I told me remember from
Catholic school which was where one
thing I remember from Sunday school was
always those martyrs those saints or
whatever all didn't turn out so well for
him in the end like that's like that's
true right I always had many stories and
then he was crucified upside down and
his head chopped got burned at the stake
I'm like and I love how this show
incorporates that Catholic sort of kind
of like baggage with it and really taps
into it and like if you're raised Roman
Catholic it's kind of a fun show to
watch yeah been there done that yeah no
and I think that's it they're still
coming have it even though I concern
myself agnostic I'm open and stuff
there's still a respect when you we
brought up with this religion you see
somebody tackle it in a smart clever way
that incorporates like hey we see we see
the possibilities of this too we see the
value in terms of not just like
religious elements but just good
storytelling and I'm just a size and
epicness and it's not up I mean if they
really can feel huge what I like about
this show is like a lot of shows we use
any religion or a lot of shows and
movies we use any religion is window
dressing whether it be Catholicism
Buddhism Christianity at large Judaism
like a lot of times it's just like oh
here's this thing needs this or here's
some Catholic mystical mumbles I'm gonna
so it just because yeah yeah and this
one has real respect for the religion
it's not just like well here's just some
window dressing a very clever way yeah
it's actually worked in and feels like
so much of a part of it to the point
that I almost sometimes wonder how many
of the writers are people involved in
this we're actually Catholic or this is
just something they picked up but I love
it so yeah and even if you look at like
whatever not religion but war or
whatever just just good storytelling you
know there's definitely a respect for it
and I think that's one of the things
where it's like sort of the anti
religious angle is that they tried to
make it you know too simple and just
good and bad and at the fair enough I
mean I'm not going like I don't get that
but there is also this understanding of
of going deeper and they're like these
grand stories did come from this you
know from these grand setups
they worked him in very cleverly and
they did write about him and people have
it ready about for a long time because
it is huge it's just grand and epic and
massive and I like a superhero show
that's kind of smaller budget with a guy
just fighting in the city can just make
it feel so grand by incorporating these
themes in there we have literally
reviewed movies that use like a Catholic
mythos of there's wood between good and
evil and the devil is gonna declare
water that it starts pulling out things
like Archangel Gabriel and this and that
thump a movie is based around that and
I'm like you know you never really got
it you just opened up like a couple of
pages of the Bible were just like well
I'm just gonna pull some of this shit
out and like this one actually gets the
themes on an intellectual level yeah
just like here here's the devil fighting
the Archangel Gabriel because we wanted
some Catholic shit in this thing yeah
here's here's Clark Kent talking with a
picture of Jesus in the background you
know it that's that's the stupid
bullshit but here they're actually I
want you to go into this cuz I can
already see some people but you hanging
you sit there and semantics there they
go you need to do between stuff when
there's been down like five episodes
where daredevil talks to three from in
at church but no but there are games it
reconciles at like well first of all
that's assume where they actually talk
what happens in the story you know is
actually what's being reflected there
talks are there too but it's she has
something to when they really talk it
sounds like they're really talking and
actually I won't have been that scene in
Manistee if they took out that fucking
picture of Jesus that would have been a
great scene that would have been a good
scene in Man of Steel if he was just
talking to the priest like that but then
having the distracting Jesus symbolism
there was too distracting it too much on
them and you know what makes the scenes
in daredevil work that one there's no
distracting imagery you don't need to
put a giant picture Gina Kaiser you'll
see the crucifixes it's in the story it
when was when the priest is talking
about good and evil half his face is in
shadow and half is in light like it's
all about close-ups and framing your
shots and faces and not being like oh is
it obvious enough we're talking about
here's a picture of Jesus like you know
there's been this big thing with like
you know symbolism and symbols and great
filmmakers use it and they have in the
past but I think there is almost for
some filmmakers and storytellers there's
a little too much relying on them and
they sort of lost some lost the element
of just the feel of it you just get the
feel I think okay instead of just here's
a picture reflecting it goes back to Mad
Max as all good things um but we were
talking about how there's so little
dialogue in that movie it's all visual
have if you pick one or the other it
could work I wouldn't have minded that
Jesus the the stained-glass windows so
prominently in the background if the
conversation were more subtle if the
conversation were subtle and they wanted
to say Oh visually this is what we're
talking about even though it sounds like
maybe they're talking about something
else this and that that would have been
fine but it is so obviously of Jesus
metaphor in their conversation that it's
completely unnecessary whereas daredevil
there's way more dialogue and it's even
more obvious there but it's not trying
to flash it in your face with other
imagery it's like no we'll let them do
the talking and this and that so it's
kind of like you kind of gotta pick one
or the other are you gonna say this
visually or is it gonna be a bunch of
talking and you can be more subtle about
it but like I think Man of Steel like
just wanted to do both at the same time
it's like too much and you can go you
know totally I mean mostly visual - I
mean even down to just color you know
the Star Wars a good guy wears white the
bad guy wears black that's about oh yeah
I mean like you know big cowboys and the
old cereal since I mean this is always
you know that is technically symbolism
you know it's using colors as you come
it's very obvious to do that Man of
Steel because it's all great but um but
ya know I really respect how this would
actually whether they really think about
hey how can we incorporate these themes
or it happens naturally I don't know it
feels like it's happening to actually go
and I my use of color like when he
decides to throw on the daredevil suit
again that yellow behind him like I just
always look like it always looks like
purgatory or something or like kind of
like
mini hell there's always yellow in the
background and then when she's talking
to a foggy in the bar gorgeously
luminous blue she's read like I don't
know if it's even intentional when
strain does it make me be could argue
she's the passion and the fire right now
and he's completely out of it and you
know there's more yellow in the
background again in the bar like it but
these scenes are so gorgeously lit and
there's so much thought put into it that
it's just it's just mind-boggling like
you could have just shot in a bar with
some lights on and not even really
thought about it that much but no they
always find an interesting way to light
every single scene or under lighted
there are times like when Wesley's
talking to Fisk you can't see either
their faces it gets kind of interesting
where they're really darkened and it's
just visually it's fascinating to watch
yeah so it's still really good episode
fucking hate on Leslie died but you know
what you do it's still it's still a
really really good episode goodbye sweet
prince
I'm most likely shoot you in the morning